[Music]
right through the city like British I'm
on a mission to get it all right through
the city like British if you ain't thick
please don't get involved
now Brandon
what is happening thickies it is Monday
morning May 16th
here we are man Calabasas thick boy
studios are in Calabasas the team's
laughing you know one thing about doing
a fight show man when there's these
lulls in big fights and you gotta come
up with material man it is you know you
you gotta get creative kids and that's
part of the gig if it was huge
pay-per-views every week everybody would
do it so here we are man hope you guys
are having a great start to your week it
is Monday morning coming in hot
everywhere's getting hot speaking of hot
licked up the weather in Philly I'm in
Philly this Thursday Friday Saturday at
the Gila Mountain Philly one of my
favorite cities I will be linking up
with my boys
every show you uh well every food truck
uh that you've seen me do except for
Patty and uh volkanovsky because they
were short notice I couldn't get the
shoes in time but my boys at suplex
sneakers out in
um Philly they're the ones who provide
all there's my other there's you those
that provide all the shoes for the food
truck Diaries
um those are my boys man and I will be
there on Saturday I'm just hanging out
probably buying shoes and um we're doing
a special uh thick boy and suplex collab
with merch uh dad hats and a dope tee uh
designed by my boy Reuben so uh come get
a manatees hats I'll be there chilling
buying shoes and uh I think we're doing
around noon or so on Saturday and that's
in Philly so if you're around Philly
come on out come chill come sneak your
shop with your boy there on Saturday but
I will be doing shows Thursday Friday
Saturday in Philly with the squad I'm
looking forward to it man it is an all
new hour it's the trash Panda tour the
trash Panda tour that's in Philadelphia
and then we're on to Portland Oregon
June 9th through the 11th then San
Francisco Cobbs is June 17th through the
18th that's got a lot of west coast
thank God and then uh San Diego's Laugh
Factory San Diego great Club in the
heart of San Diego downtown San Diego
July 21st through July 23rd that's it
man but other than that good weekend
your boy finally got some rest watch the
fights chilled with the kiddos got the
kiddos uh Dairy Queen and uh listen man
I grew up on Dairy Queen that was my dad
would take me to Dairy Queen there's not
a lot of them anymore there's not a ton
of Dairy Queens I don't know if just
kind of went to the Wayside I don't know
what's happening there I don't know if
Orange Julius owns them but
um my kids love ice cream and I was like
oh it's Sunday let's go my dad used to
always take me to Dairy Queen and they
used to like make flurries in this fancy
ice cream and Calabasas and all that
other [ __ ] so I was like man what we
do what I did when I was a kid I'm
taking it a blizzard
there's no Dairy Queens really in the
valley it was a nightmare to find one
finally found one inside of a mall and
uh we get them and they were not having
it they were not impressed you gotta be
honest I wasn't impressed I haven't had
one in I mean [ __ ]
ten years I don't know Dairy Queen We
see them they were not feeling them man
I gotta be honest one thing to them is
uh those big flurries are hard to beat
those McFlurries they're a little
thicker a little better quality I'll
give them that you don't realize you
know when you're a kid you're thinking
one thing and when you as an adult you
try it out it
in a slap in the face man like a wet
dick it uh it was disappointing it was
disappointing man they didn't even need
it I was like well what no who doesn't
eat ice cream yeah the hell they were
not impressed but uh yeah man so two
thumbs down for Dairy Queen from the
kiddos and then uh
uh the Press tour continue for the
special we're gonna hit a million son
we're on track we got 10 days baby 10
days if we keep at the current Pace
we're gonna pass a million views on the
new special the green girl poppy uh the
Press tour continued here in LA because
I stopped at Adam carollas Adam is one
of my favorite people on the freaking
planet and uh he's just such a good
freaking dude man he's uh he's one of
the North Stars if you think about my
business model it's very similar to Adam
carollas and I realized once I got to a
studio in his Studio which is way cooler
than mine he was like cars everywhere
and all this all his stuff that he's
done is all over the walls and he we
were talking about you know he has his
own alcohol he crushes it with that you
know I have my out call you go to
thickboy.com right now and get you some
of that tiger thick which they've sold
out and then restocked and I posted but
it was sold out and they've restocked
minutes later thank God but uh
yeah Adam's doing the damn thing and he
was just talking about schedule I was
like yeah I'm just sick of talking this
you know I have my own shows to do and
I'm doing promotion on top of it and
blah blah blah he's like hey how many
shows you do a week I was like you know
any given week man you know four to five
then you add in the promotion you're
talking you know I did I think 12 shows
in six days when I was doing the promo
stuff like that he was right right right
I could tell you know he's not like ah
man hang in there he's uh and I I go uh
what's your schedule he's like oh man
I'll do uh
you know three shows at least a day two
hours long I go oh like Monday Tuesday
Wednesday yes no every day
Monday through Friday sometimes
Saturdays
every day three shows at least two hours
he's like yeah like no doubt man hell
yeah I'm not tired he's just a beast
dude he's just a beast he's so talented
man such a good dude he might be popping
up on job and Friends next Wednesday on
the 25th might be popping up daddy so
shout out to Adam curler we had such a
good time man he's such a good dude but
uh
I was relieved because I had to actually
watch the fights in real time didn't
have to record them or hear people tell
me about them even though it was just a
fight night that main event was lit but
if I had to give MVP the MVP is not
going to Jan blockovich who won because
uh Rocky Blue is freaking tendon out
which if you've seen the replay it you
can see that thing like a rubber band
I felt bad for racket man I felt bad for
him bad injury although with you know
technology and you know doctors today
and the you know the advancement in
technology and Medicine He he'll be back
I bet early next year he's such a Savage
definitely has speed Advantage the leg
kicks he I think was we're gonna catch
up with him I'd be surprised that fight
did go all five rounds
you forget how good Yawn is though man
he let some good shots even though
racket's clearly younger more athletic
the light kicks I thought were gonna pay
dividends at the end there but
we didn't really get to see it because
if you didn't watch the fight uh I had
it 1-1 going into the third I think Jan
won the first round rocket definitely
won the second with the takedown and the
control now going to the third I was
like now now now it's getting real now
it's getting real and Jan was definitely
kind of I don't say slowing down but
racket's just a little younger athletic
quicker you know on the feet there and I
think he was trying to his right hand he
was so off in those first two rounds I
think he was gonna find the timing there
I still would have maybe slightly
favored racket uh going into these later
rounds depending on how the light kicks
uh went into it but then his uh knee was
like check please and then attendant was
like
and he just fell right to the ground and
uh lost the fight because of that so now
Jan is gonna fight the winner of uh
Glover and our boy yerry so uh Glover is
a underdog in that fight by the way and
Glover tweeted out John uh get the job
done I'll get my job done so we can do
the rematch which I love I love you know
that they're cool with each other
so I was I gotta be honest I was rooting
for Yan it's just when you lose like
that and you tell he was talking about
like all the issues had in Camp and you
know with Bisbee on the mic he was like
yeah it was just a rough Camp you know I
had diarrhea for two days like whoa dude
um he got a cut and he's dealing with
all this stuff you know he has kids so I
was just I wanted John to win I thought
it was a very very tough fight for him
that's where he's at man you know you go
from champ you're not gonna fight you
know some schmuck racket such a monster
so either way you got it done so he
moves on
um
you know I do think Yuri and rakik are
the the future of the light heavyweight
division so we will see but uh I think
surprisingly surprisingly my MBP is not
uh anybody on the main card the MVP uh
was the first fight on the prelims Andre
petrovski if you've seen this gentleman
uh he fought a a an undefeated you know
Monster and Nick maximov and uh you know
that the Nick guy was talking about
wrestling and all this [ __ ] and then
that Andre petrovski who's Philly's
Finest as well he uh you know really put
on a clinic and locked in my personal
favorite submission the anaconda joke
and he was a huge Underdog and I did bet
on him you know and I'm not that guy to
post and brag about it but I did bet on
him because I I just you know he's a
badass man he's a badass and I can't
believe they didn't give him a
performance of the night he's the
biggest Underdog on the card and got it
done in a minute 16 against an
undefeated process respect what are we
doing how do you not give that guy a
bonus
those other ones were all right not as
good as his
especially on the prelims
an undefeated guy biggest dog and he
dominated him like he shot in he got a
hold of his neck anaconda in and out see
ya thanks for thanks for the money see
you next undefeated Prospect can't get a
bonus Philly's Finest
sorry Andre
sorry dude I think you deserve it uh and
I was also relieved for Michael Johnson
as well you know he's just been you know
tough times and get to you that big
knockout win you know
been there brother so hopefully uh
hopefully feels a lot better he's been a
better mental space but uh card was
solid solid ass card man Ryan span
looked phenomenal with his Guillotine
choke uh really the main event though
kind of disappointing the way it ended
you never want to see something like
that but um yeah Jan's gonna get the
winner of Yuri Glover
and you know I do think yerry gets it
done but yerry racket is the fight dude
but we're not gonna see that no so Yuri
yawns can be tough after watching yawn
ratkick
yawns mean potatoes are better his power
is insane but [ __ ] Yuri man he's just
that wild man wild wild man my favorite
light heavyweight right now he's so fun
not a huge guy either he was at that
Mike Tyson Super Bowl show that I did he
came on the show not not a huge guy
that's thin thin yeah not a big
lightweight I mean taller but not like
very thin but just a Savage dude such a
Savage so Freon that's what's next for
him the winner of Glover Yuri I would
assume here he gets that dumb but can
never count Glover out but good fights
overall and he had Bellator as well
yet some Bellator fights going down uh
Michael Venom page of course you know
his Achilles heel uh good wrestlers it
you know they're just not going to play
a game with him is striking Second To
None So if a guy has an advantage when
it comes to wrestling grappling they're
gonna do what it takes to win the fight
and unfortunately when you do that to
Michael Venom page it turns into a
boring fight unfortunately for Michael
Venom page even Paul Daley was like I
think your wrestling's terrible I'm
gonna wrestle remember that yeah so it's
like this huge Achilles heel for him
um man it's disappointing because he's
I think by far the biggest star the you
know the style wise uh personality you
know just he has that it Factor but
unfortunately when these big moments
come they're trying to make him the face
of Bellator he loses and they if I'm
Bellator
listen man
I'm gonna make it very obvious we want
him as a champion you ain't finding any
wrestlers there's none of that [ __ ]
because you know I I heard uh Scott
Coker say you know you can't win a fight
by laying on a guy
yeah again yeah
well yeah you can though you can though
because this isn't the WWE and if a guy
is a better wrestler even though it's
boring you can definitely win a fight
like that there's guys that want a ton
of fights like that uh one that comes
mind John Fitch just took guys down over
and over and over
I don't find it boring I think it's uh
you know it's clearly a game plan that
if a guy is not great with his uh
takedown defense and you can expose that
whatever it takes man he's walking home
the interim world champion I don't care
how he got it done
and the record books don't say boring
fight just says champ I'll take it
so you know my boy little Machida
leoto you know I love you brother it
might be time let's take a little break
of me just chatting your ear off about
the fight world because you're just
wandering around right now man you're
hoping your finances are good maybe
investing crypto all that stuff nfts
maybe you're on the older side like I am
your dad like I guess things are going
to work out financially I don't know
dude take advantage take it into your
own hands and that's where massworks dot
art slash job because they're trying to
save your wallet man we're talking about
art here Art's been around forever it's
a great investment it's a safe
investment and you gotta do it with the
right people all right and there's over
400 000 people who are taking this stuff
serious and they're using Masterworks
dot art slash job to save their wallet
to save their finances again Masterworks
dot art slash shop right it's the
important regulation A disclosures at
masterworks.io CD again take control of
your finances your Investments Art's
been around forever Mass Works knows
exactly what you need to do to make sure
you're not taking these insane risks
with this crypto nfts all that stuff
talking about art baby we're talking
about art that's been around forever
it's smart invest your money wise do the
right thing let Master Works help you
out again massworks dot Art Shop you're
welcome all right you hairy people out
there yeah Harry Harry people I have an
announcement from my friends at manscape
the product alert
foreign
you asked for it the boys at manscape
they listened and listen up man manscape
brought back the ultra smooth package
it's time to stop dropping where this
premium shaving kit Everyone Knows by
now that the lawnmower 4.0 is the best
electric shave for your balls all right
it's not nicking them you're not
bleeding it's easy there's a light on it
all right but now the the ultra smooth
package is the perfect set man it's time
to shave that bush of yours and get
right to the root with a discount just
for you get 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com with the code shop20
schaub20 the ultra smooth package is
specialized groin shaving kit to help
you buff protect and smooth your most
sensitive areas it's scary it's scary
I'm talking crop shaver razor crop a
foliator the crop gel men you no longer
have to borrow your ladies razor to get
this the piece going man you don't want
that man you got ingrown hairs you're
nicking your nuts they're bleeding
non-stop you know how it is you Nick
your nuts it's a freaking flood the
blood it's just nuts you don't have to
do that anymore man manscapes Ultra
smooth package is a three-step kit to
make your package the perfect package we
got you man you want to grab your handy
lawnmower 4.0 all right give your boys a
classic trim see I'm good with that man
but if you're not you you can uh the
crop of foliator infused with
ingredients that can soothe clear and
keep the skin on all around your groin
just ready to go man all right in the
crop gel you know again they have
essential oils it's like spa treatment
for your nuts man the crop shaver was
designed for shaving the growing area
man it's designed for that any other
Shavers you know that are designed for
that nope all right it's time to get up
close and personal with the best tools
for the job the ultra smooth package
from manscape get 20 off and free
shipping with the code shop20 SCH ab20
at manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping with code shop20 at
manscape.com smooth out your fellas with
the relaunch Ultra smooth package you
smooth like a seal bill for my friends
at manscape your balls will thank you I
remember when I when him and I were
training together all the time and I go
how long you want to do this man he said
another 10 years I'm like what he just
loves fighting it's in his blood man he
loves fighting I don't know what his
plans are now but you know I think it
was he's lost four in a row now let's
take a look it's dicey dude
and I just you know I he he's a straight
fighters fighter as a Fighter's heart
but you know so
yep
so yeah man
it is tough gagard Split Decision
some might say it's the best
middleweight on the planet it's up for
debate with Izzy why Izzy Musashi take
whatever money you want guys we're never
gonna see that but so you know last
here's the thing
you can say all right Machida time to
retire and then you look if you just go
through it so he lost Gengar Musashi
debatable best middleweight on the
planet
definitely won a1b no argument there
Phil Davis
Split Decision
Gengar Split Decision Ryan Bader I think
Vader is the fifth or sixth overall
ranked heavyweight in the world he's
also the world champion beltor decision
and then he got you know got ko'd in the
first round by Fabian Edwards so I don't
know if it's like oh it's time I don't
know if it's time maybe you're just not
at the you know front of the queue
anymore
maybe you're right outside that you know
you're not you're not at the top of the
summit anymore you're you're going to go
down a couple notches and freeze with
the other boys trying to climb Mount
Everest you know
it is what it is but I think it's weird
to say that he's done done he needs to
hang him up when you look at out of the
four losses three of the four are close
decisions two split decisions the
world-class Talent
and three decisions just straight up
upper echelon guys and Bader champ
Musashi champ Phil Davis former champ
the Fabian Edwards one bad I get it but
the arguments say he should hang it up I
don't see that yet I don't see it yet
now if he fights another time and gets
absolutely starch and some brutal kale
now we can have that discussion but off
this no not yet
not yet the MMA Community is too quick
to be like done like Jesus Christ dude
you know
what can you do shout out to machita
what else you got chin am I miss
anything else uh not as far as fights
but uh so Fabian Edwards is uh I think
Leon edwards's younger brother
um yeah makes sense
God can Leon Edwards get a freaking
fight dude him and Kamara let's go here
I know
all right so this is cool this is Paul
Daly's retirement fight he was
originally supposed to fight Andre
kreshkov which I didn't enjoy for his
retirement yeah it's like God damn
trying to what are you trying to do
exactly so this is his KR here
of his new apartment really the best
fight that is going on is the Amber
Heard Johnny Depp drop let's be honest
it's still going that is the most lit
thing to that big UFC paper you know
nothing is fantastic all right carry on
oh
what a oh
wow what a walk-off
yeah that was a super cool knockout
that's how he was retirement fight yeah
that's great good for him man
and this is the bad one this is machito
getting knocked out by Fabian Edwards
Vegeta's style too he's not a guy like
if you're uh like mainly wrestler
Grappler you can hang in there a little
longer towards the end of your career
like a child did or something like that
but if you're like if you pride yourself
on footwork and quickness and movement
and then as you get older that's the
first thing to go that's why
heavyweights can fight longer than
anybody else because the power is the
last thing you go but as far as if
you're like a footwork guy like once
Wonder Boy
you know once that's that timing and
speed and quickness goes down man it's a
tough gig Leona machito same thing he
Prides himself I mean quick in and out
footwork and once you get older that's
the first thing to go it gets dicey man
yeah
yeah so many fights Rashad Evans
oh
yeah he was a big one too that's a big
win yeah it's tough yeah still don't
think he's done done
you said one more we'll see what happens
yeah if that happens again then we can
have the conversation
this happened over the weekend too which
I had no idea about but there's a btfc
where Houston Alexander actually fought
do you know what kind of savage you have
to be to fight [ __ ] Houston Alexander
bare knuckle
yeah he was super scary when he was in
the UFC all right so I'll just show you
hopefully bkfc will let us use this but
be cool be KFC be cool man
pause real quick
go back is the am I crazy or does that
the drink say fart time
does it say fart time no does that not
say fart time it does it looks fan fan
time I think
see right here you can see this side oh
gotcha
energy called Fart time that'd be cool
all right I see that's fan time sorry at
the same time not part time God who is
he fighting
and then he followed up ground and pound
which is I think frowned upon Him bare
knuckle yeah I got a it's kind of like
boxing where you can't follow the guy
down and throw a [ __ ] Dan Henderson
flying elbow you know yeah but
that's just is you know that's the way
his body's wired the guy goes down I
know I finish it that guy was out out
yeah Houston Alexander man you know if
when he was coming up remember he's the
pride in Nebraska before Crawford was
and he was you know Nebraska Husker had
walked on Husker gear and [ __ ] yeah he
was badass man
badass terrible fight with Kimbo but
badass and he had like the best or one
of the best bodies back then short
compact it was just like a little chat
yeah
uh Frank Gore his uh boxing debut he won
by knockout
and it was pretty hardcore knockout too
now no this isn't his debut because he
fought Darren uh was it Darren
Williamson during something at the the
other NBA an NBA player So Pro debut oh
gotcha so he lost that one you know what
let's go bro let's go bro
all right Jake well it worked out from
here
dude he was such a good
oh you such a good running back really
here's the thing about Frank Gore
you know he had his brain scanned they
found a bunch of white spots all over it
so he was worried about getting uh
passed by the commission
he's like I'm fine man you think you
know I want to be there for my kid do
you think I'd risk all that for I think
I paid 330 000. it's like yeah
because if they bring did my brain scan
I had a bunch of white spots all over it
I never hit in any facet see there's you
see Scott Coker rips judging Logan's
story Michael page you're just laying on
somebody and to me that's not MMA it is
though no Scott I love you man
it is though yeah you can stop it like
stop it if you can't stop it you know
that's like being mad like dude if
you're just gonna punch guy in the face
that's not MMA
well then stop him from punching in the
face it's one of the aspects of MMA yeah
grappling is one of the aspects of mixed
martial arts it's no different than if
all guy does is Win off leg kicks and
the other guy just wins off grappling
and wrestling it's part of the game I
know it now now he should say if you're
just laying on somebody to me that's not
exciting and you're not going in there
to win that's fine you're not risking
you know to win
might have an argument there but to say
it's not mma's and that's that's an
issue because then wrestler's like ah
[ __ ] man you know they're like oh man he
hates when I do this you know
and then you become John Fitch where
most 99.9 of the population fighting
can't stop you but they have this weird
pressure in the back your mind yeah you
kept winning but as soon as he's like
the last part they just got rid of him
yes yeah because the excitement wasn't
there for some fans I mean think about
the argument that uh khabib's you know
the goat the best ever do it
you know straight Grappler
now he would finish guys but a lot of
times straight Grappler
all right and but khabib was also
exciting too not all the time but he had
those moments like for sure oh yeah for
sure yeah I'm just saying you know it's
like but that's his his mentality was to
break you go in the rep I here's the
thing let you guys know I guarantee you
that Logan story his plan was to break
Michael Venom page like van page is hard
to break but his goal was to be khabib
and I guarantee break him down through
grappling and Venom page just figured it
out
didn't break you know but lost the fight
yeah
all right so uh you mentioned Wonderboy
earlier
so Dustin Poirier has been tweeting
something out like he pretty much called
out all the 155ers and won seven years I
know he accepted Colby Covington yeah
Colby Dustin take my money
so take my money let's just go there
uh that's what he says here Colby
Covington I accept July 30th now I heard
Colby is dealing with some issues from
the Sucker Punch though his teeth and
his head okay yeah that sucks
so
but dude July 30th you'll see 277 you
Colby Diamond
filthy yep
now has Colby responded or no
oh thank you what so when did he he
called him out after the the fight right
against no even afterwards he was on a
show I guess this was like um a podcast
or something Reckless me oh no
Covington uh had called out pory
following United decision over
horizontal in March pay-per-view he says
that fight needs to happen he talked too
reckless in the media he said it's on
site and last time he was talking to you
clickbait Merchants he was saying oh I'm
not gonna fight Kobe not gun where's uh
uh where there's finances on the line
I'm gonna fight him in the streets and
we're both going to go to jail it's
funny it's very ironic because he talks
about being a Family Guy good guy he
wants to fight me in the streets and
potentially go away from his family
Justin poy has all these uh stipulations
to fight me I just have one stipulation
my stipulation is he lets the world
watch and enjoy themselves I'm with uh
oh yeah with Colby on this yeah yeah and
then Dustin goes I accept yeah well
that's a great backstory done and done
yeah the ATT you know story and
I'm in I'm into
all right so this also happened over the
weekend in the UFC Andrea Lee her coach
called uh well she was he was telling
her watch out for these the dirty
Brazilians which some people took as
like a racist thing but then he also
came out saying now real quick to
backstory to Andrew Lee if she's not
with her husband anymore her husband
also had the Nazi stuff
I don't know what's good so they're in
the corner and he goes be careful these
dirty Brazilians he was they're dirty
[ __ ] Brazilians they're gonna [ __ ]
cheat like that because he was regarding
he was saying something about eye pokes
so but he said dirty [ __ ] if you say
dirty and then someone's you know
country it gets a little tricky it ah
it's a stretch I think when we're
talking about fighting and
um who's a coach Tony Kelly so he fought
yeah so Tony Kelly's been in there
there's certain
cancel cancel cultures where what I said
was real and In the Heat of the battle
and no way had any type of racist
connotations but if that's the way you
take it I don't give a [ __ ] so many
people quit to say racist that shit's
getting so old my reference was to dirty
eye poke yeah that's fair yeah I'm just
saying when you combine the dirty and
that people are going to think things
but in this particular case he's also in
the middle yeah of a fist fight giving
her you know be like okay be careful
about like you're not thinking of like
cancel culture like again I'm with him
like this cancer culture thing like oh
he's racist dirty Brazilian it's like
what you know I'm sure you could have
said in other ways he shouldn't have to
censor himself inside that octagon
the uh if this is becomes a thing UFC
shouldn't mic up that octagon or play it
after the fact edit out and play out
because these guys shouldn't be worried
about man if I say something that people
don't like I'm gonna get criticism like
we don't want because then culture's
gonna sense the coach is going to censor
themselves it'll affect their code same
with Like Comics that read comments you
know what I'm saying
and then it just changes the way that
you're gonna do how you think you should
do it then you're dictating and you're
kind of going with um and if I say this
this is gonna you know the YouTube
comments gonna say this and then you're
not getting your best self if that makes
sense so with coaches we don't want them
censoring themselves it's not racist
yeah there's real racism what happened
in Buffalo is racism that Manifesto is
racism there's actual racism so when you
guys make this a headline you're taken
away from actual racism that exists
you're not helping the cause you're
actually hurting it
yep
all right this also happened Nate Diaz
posted this picture of him peeing
outside the ufcpi center taking a piss
on the UFC Pi we're just peeing I know
trash
I could do this because I get paid more
than all you guys when she used to space
there whatever and they won't cut me
yeah I like what he's doing he's really
poking the bear there
um here's my thing I will piss anywhere
outside there's not a better feeling in
this world it's the close thing I'll get
to being a health angel I feel like such
a rebel when I piss outside I dude I
jump out of the car pee in my yard I
love it before I go in the pool I pee in
my yard okay not in the pool though good
no not in the pool my kids are in there
man we did have a fat rat who thought he
could swim died in there now usually if
there's like a bee or something in the
pool I will save him put him back on you
know hard property let them fly dry off
and fly off but this rat you know you
yeah when I just looked down it was not
like he was swimming you know because I
would have saved him even though it's a
rat I would have saved him with a we got
like the the pool thing but he you know
it must have happened when I was
sleeping he long tailman wrapped it to
me all up in there man nasty Mike we
came out my son goes dad that rat's
sleeping like he is in the water not
sleeping because they can't sleep in
water it's not fish right buddy so he is
actually visiting with God right now
all right so Evander Holyfield's son
Evan Holyfield was he like a minus ten
thousand yeah I think he was undefeated
until this point how many fights did he
have like 10 or something like that
uh six and hold on
so he fought uh a German minus ten
thousand favorites yeah so I'm saying
legit minus ten thousand favorite like
nobody's betting that well bet on the
other guy
one dollar to win 10 000.
well I don't know if he was a plus ten
thousand that'd be no one's doing that
he got knocked out bad though huh yeah
I'll show you in a second uh he went in
9-0 yeah
okay what happened let me show you here
we go
foreign
[Music]
that was
such a hot shot
ah he was getting up early yeah
but that was a really bad punch
there's another angle
that right
oh my goodness what a turn of events he
cracked his jaw
a little early yeah I think so
especially for boxing yeah some [ __ ] and
boxing boy he got crap
so that sucks for their fans you never
want to do that you know
all right Vincente luque Vince Vicente
Luce and Jeff Neal The Roadhouse or
Steakhouse dude dude whatever that is
he's still there he's not there I don't
think anymore hopefully not it's a great
fight yeah got some of these bad events
Prime Fight Night are fantastic dude
remember they've been like putting
fights together amazing oh the
combinations dude cater and uh like an
Emmett yeah yeah doggy
um this I think even [ __ ] uh Curtis
blades and aspinall is a fight night in
London we should probably do a uh
fighting for that when is that uh July
or June end of June
and the girl meatballs on that as well
oh yeah
March 19th no that's uh that was the
last one March but then there's another
July 23rd there you go
uh-huh you're not on tour or anything uh
I don't know okay we'll find either way
we'll figure it out yeah if I'm not
we'll do one
um so okay Brandon Moreno and Kai car
friends two is targeted for UFC 277. I
dig that is there an intern yeah because
Davidson I guess he messed up his finger
I'll show you what he posted here but it
looks weird this picture looks a little
weird yeah his finger looks very strange
there how long is he out for and why is
he look like uh Bobby's that's what
here's the thing his finger looks
crooked but so does his head yeah what
about your head dude
hey Megamind why does he look like this
I don't know but I'm not sure how long
he's off for but if it's a finger injury
I don't think it's gonna be that long
ah there's a thing dirty effing
Brazilians video shows Angelique coach
with bigoted cornering no dude he's
referring to cheating and that's also
click bait to you it's not oh 100 that's
the headlines man it's referring to the
act of cheating not Brazilians in as a
whole
could have used different he could have
said it differently but again we don't
want to censor the cornerman
uh yeah so figure it was out with that
weird finger yeah
uh this is a pretty cool matchup Paul
Craig and Volcan ozdemere
that's gonna be a you'll see Lindy too I
am in that's fantastic that's on UFC
London yeah man I'm telling you if I'm
in town yeah that's July 23rd I might be
in San Diego matter of fact I'm pretty
sure
yep
July 23rd Saturday night that's okay
there's a million fight nights in June
July we'll find we'll we'll make
something happen the year when you're
you're out of town too right
I think I'm in Portland right yeah yeah
so skip on that one we'll see okay
we shall see all right
I hate missing companions mm-hmm
but I see why Rogan doesn't do them
does that make sense it's a lot of work
I mean I don't it's my favorite show to
do it's fun it's just when you're a
touring comic like my age when I was
like hey man can you make sure you line
up with the UFC schedule he's like no
what
stuff yeah
okay this one I didn't see coming but
Bobby green you just had him on the show
and Jim Miller That's UFC yeah Bobby's
doing that on uh food truck recently but
then most recently that dropped last
week sure we're trying to get off the
ground uh trying to has one leg right
now trying to get two legs if you want
to pay attention to it I sit down it's
called Fight Night flashbacks and it's
where I sit down with uh a fighter and
we go through kind of the most important
fights of their career and the last one
that aired last week is with Bobby green
we go through
you know his fights we go through his
fights he would go through this fight
with uh makachav uh we go through
I forget which other ones but they're
fun to sit down I think this week we're
gonna sit down I'm gonna go over my
losses maybe with Eric Griffin
just to mix it up yeah so uh it's a fun
show though man really really fun show
with Eric Griffin of all people just
because he's not I my idea of doing it
with Eric is because he's not of like
balls deep and fighting and his reaction
seeing me get [ __ ] up that would be
hilarious yeah because he's gonna ask
questions like what I think most people
like dude what we you know yeah I think
it could just something different but
it's a great show it's fun
but Bobby green Jim Miller is fantastic
yeah two Wiley vets man
another fight announcement well we
already knew this but it's so Cowboys
starting versus Joe design has been
moved you know Cowboy couldn't something
happen yeah yeah great that's rebooked
for June 18th see June 18th yep I don't
know if I'm in town on that one either
but we'll figure it out
uh another quick Nate Diaz one he called
out Chandler see I I'm telling you I
took if you go back and listen to the
last weeks I told you you know when he's
doing these call-outs everybody thinks
towards McGregor or whoever I think it's
towards freaking Chandler
no one's thinking it I really think it
because channel is healthy he's ready to
go right now all these other guys he
can't fight this is who he's referring
to
get me on ice for a year now Chandler's
obviously ready to fight Senate contract
it's time
and dude I think if I'm UFC again invest
in Chandler because Chandler can fight
Nate Diaz he'd be favored in that fight
let's say he were to beat Nate Diaz
then McGregor's coming back early next
year Chandler's ready to go have him
take out these two pay-per-view kingpins
yeah invest in general because he still
has work to do and then the the the kind
of marketing and fan base for channel
goes through the roof you have he beats
Nate all right now he takes out [ __ ]
McGregor then he fights for the title
it's like dude do you hate money let's
see
yeah huge star power after that
uh but also let me do whatever the [ __ ]
you want give him a fight so we can get
out and do it I know what's to do give
him a fight quit holding these guys
hostage
it's ridiculous he clearly wants to
fight
um all right so he pissed on your office
building for God he's trying to get cut
yeah
all right so Floyd Mayweather and
Anderson Silver they're supposed to not
together but they're supposed to fight
other people it's made of that comen
event right I think something like that
yeah yeah so with uh May weather is with
an old training partner and then Silva
was like another MMA guy in the box so
silly but then uh the president of the
UAE passed away so now that it's been
called off
yeah yeah I I've seen I know how it
works out there so follow me on this
I've skeptical hippo eyes I think a this
is a good reason to pull the fight
especially out there for that guy
passing away I think they like shut
everything down fair point but I think
for them just like all right we're out
we're not doing it they could have just
rescheduled like whatever how long they
want their uh kind of sad time to go for
I I think they were looking at the
analytics we're like dude there's no
exposure like I had no idea what's
happening yeah I think in general like
dude nobody's paying attention look this
isn't the move we're gonna lose our ass
it's just Kansas thing we have a legit
reason now don't reschedule just cancel
it and we'll figure it out the next move
because this ain't you guys find these
two nobodies is not good that's what's
happening I think
and this is a great reason yeah
all right so Tony Ferguson you know I
guess he's been sort of just doing his
own stuff his own Camp really training
by himself like he went away from all of
his coaches or his team so now he's
saying he wants to be with the team
again and he wants to be at 170. do you
say what team he's still looking around
I think he mentioned Jackson's and even
like old school freaking uh chuckle
dolls coach oh uh uh how come how come
yeah that'd be great cope man he would
mix really well with heckleman
okay
wait Ferguson accuses DC of cocaine
click on that God could talk about these
clickbaits where is it at this one
that's sitting on the middle in the red
if you go the middle says Ferguson oh
gosh
I can't believe I'm entertainment
cocaine use after weigh in conflict
uh oh this way in Conflict how not to
make weight ladies and gentlemen should
have stripped them like they did Charles
Brown shout out to all those doing it
right keeping this work clean champ
can't wait wait and they're saying he's
on cocaine
uh freezing didn't take Kylie Corey's
reply however telling Corey to laugh the
yay slang term for cocaine if you didn't
know that you're a boomer uh he also
brought up khabib fat head
uh Tony please oh here's DC
Tony please stop go sit back for a
little tuck your head in a hole
somewhere regroup man recover spend some
time with your family like just please
stop I plead with you it's not a good
look like you're making me sad yeah it
makes me sad too keep going down lay off
the yay buddy not good look you make
yourself look sad I'm already back to
work I don't quit like you enjoy your
retirement with fat head interesting
yeah Tony is very upset
Bruce is insane that DC is cocaine safe
can we
yeah yeah of all things cocaine though I
would never even
uh so this so uh DC put uh at Tony B
camera because this guy uh P kit at Peak
kit Zeke said Ferguson's insulating that
DC is on cocaine seems like that can be
obvious and exposed friction too much
more than just criticism trash talk is
one thing but defamatory statements are
another probably no damage because DC is
damn guy but sure seems odd yeah that's
that's the thing with like
you know defamation of character stuff
like that that's even
like the narrative on me which I don't
talk about with you know I have a
lawsuit against this YouTuber who's a
small time YouTuber if you don't know
the background you're like oh it's this
guy who's Big in the space doing the
smaller guy no no I don't give a [ __ ] if
you want to criticize my fight picks or
my stand-up my podcast that's what I'm a
public figure I signed up for that that
stuff does not bother me but when you
start slandering my name stealing
content and creating this false
Narrative of cheating on my wife and
doing all this crazy [ __ ] and the
defamatory stuff and using content in
the clickbait stuff like that for years
well then you're we're not playing the
same game man then I have to do
something if you made an entire career
off defamation I have to do something
several times I've had my team reach out
and go we don't want to pursue this dude
just stop and he wouldn't
so what would you do
so this narrative that oh this this
bigger YouTuber suing this other
YouTuber for no reason to silence him
because you know I thought you didn't
get down with cancel culture I don't any
facet
this is different you got you got to
know your facts you gotta know your
details so this goes the only reason I
bring that because with Tony Ferguson
when you say this do you see a guy who's
a public figure and is associated with
Brands like myself yeah yeah and when
you say cocaine use or drug use or this
other stuff it's gonna affect his bottom
dollar and that's when this has to be
addressed
if you don't say oh he has the shittiest
flight picks or he's bad at English or
you know I didn't like his stand up I
think Louis CK is better no [ __ ] that's
fine that's all good that's fine but
then when when you start going down that
dark Road man you start going down you
know the these these clip baby things
that are defamation of character for
years years hundreds of videos for years
when I got my attention
that's where this goes
let's don't talk about it and the
problem when you don't talk about it is
people can jump to assumptions go oh
this this bigger guy is trying to
science little guy because he's critical
now you're kidding me how many people
are correct I don't give that doesn't
bother me be critical that's what I
signed up for
but the defamation now you got my
attention you start doing this evil
stuff I'm gonna come for you man that's
what's happening yeah when they mess
with your livelihood that's just you
start messing with my business my family
trust me
I'm gonna come for you yeah well I'm
glad you kind of discussed it a little
bit
and I to be honest after going
everything I've been through
I'm always a guy and you guys know I'm
always glass half full you're gonna get
criticism you're gonna get hate you just
keep on keeping on them I've always said
that I'm like a [ __ ] race or
something here I don't pay attention
the problem with that
kind of
attitude or that business model is
if you don't address some things people
can jump to conclusions and come up with
their own narratives that aren't gonna
you know you need to say why you're
doing it sometimes you have to address
that stuff otherwise it's a bad look
it can be about and I'm and I'm learning
you know even though I've been doing
this for 10 000 hours I'm you know I'm
learning oh when it's something that
major you should probably address it and
make it very clear yeah
now I know
there you go man
um so Kane Velasquez is his lawyer as
his attorney they just they just is
there how old is this this was uh before
my boy just texted and I denied him bail
because the father came out and said the
shot did something to an artery and he
can't work anymore
he's unable to work let me see the exact
thing he said
yeah there's an update on it uh Judd
just denied Kane's bail the father got
shot spoke said his artery was severed
and he can never work again Judd said
public opinion doesn't rule the law does
denied bail
not ideal
damn this is tough man yeah it's tough
man
um yeah I mean you know obviously the
public opinion Kane's beloved and you
know we're he's fighting a good fight I
think but you know the law is very black
and white here you know unfortunately
man it's such a shame it says here uh
Bender first of all says Cain Velasquez
has no respect for human life he doesn't
care about the rule of law if given the
opportunity I think you will try to
finish what he started Jesus Christ
it's uh what about
the years of being a stand-up citizen of
professional world-class athlete a great
dad a face of the UFC a Spate uh the
face of you know mexican-americans what
about all again all the what about all
the years where he was a great model
Citizen and that just goes out the
window it's kind of like through this
cancer culture you have to go back 10
years and find a tweet
10 years and you want to cancel over 10
years ago what about the thousands of
tweets since then that shows this great
person they've evolved that doesn't
matter
with Kane all the years of being a great
human being all those years
and then one incident now he's this
Reckless disregard for human life off
one incident
it's insane it's an incident that
everyone agrees they would do the same
thing too
if they found out something like that
happened you'd freaking lose your mind
can't even imagine yeah
yeah it's a he's in such a tough spot
man you got if you're a Cain Alaska's
fan you have to pray this goes to a
juror to a jury and it's not up to this
judge who's clearly not playing with him
clearly already thinks he's a human [ __ ]
fighter you have this Old Judge who's
stuck in her ways has to go to a jury
and got that jury of 12 has kids and
like we get it it was a moment of rage
and he gets three years he's he's
getting time guaranteed gets done but
three years compared to 20 20 you're
missing out on your children's lives
that's the other thing like with this
judge like hold on
so he's defend his kids I get it had a
moment of rage horrible what he did
should do some time
but if you give him more than three
years now not only are you affecting the
so the the child that was molesting
these other kids are molested at that
daycare
now they don't have their father in
their lives so what's more important to
you
if you if you look at this as just a
human being and you step back and you
look you go right who's affected here
okay you didn't kill anybody he tried
moment of rage but how is this going to
affect what's better for Society Kane
and his kids lives and his can feed his
family and they keep it going he's a
good person his wife is a good person
and they raise these children to be you
know to contribute to society because
he's a good person 99.9 of his life he's
been a good person had one mistake
nobody died nobody died
think about it you put them away for 20
years that entire family is [ __ ] dude
you're ruining those kids
not to mention I don't know exactly who
it is in this family the therapy the the
PTSD the trauma that kids can have
you're going to take away his father
or her father
you know yeah man it's so freaking
terrible horrible
okay moving on from this uh Dana White
said this is not that new but he said
that uh
Fighters can no longer carry Flags to
the Octagon or even show Flags in the
Octagon anymore
and then cool I haven't seen this then
the quote says you guys know why yeah
that's as far as he goes with it
and I think in this article they're kind
of insinuating that you know certain
countries won't want to watch because
there's a like in the Ukraine and
Russian thing going on too so that's
that's what they're alluding to but
that's not you know solid
and they want to make the more you know
more money making sure everyone watches
is a [ __ ] ton of Russians Pakistani and
stuff like that
they don't want to side with Russia
I don't I gotta be honest and this is
you know I I take all full
accountability on this I don't know the
lay of the land over there with like
Dagestan Siberia Bulgaria like Russia
like that whole area I don't know the
Dynamics of where they side and all that
[ __ ] in Ukraine and all that stuff you
know yeah to like Yugoslavia and all
that you know even Afghanistan Iraq Iran
like all that [ __ ] I don't know exactly
where they side yeah so I don't I can't
give you the smartest opinion on this
um but to take away all Flags
a little dicey right yeah because you
want to represent your country
it's a huge honor you know
yeah but they do show it when they're
walking out you know where they're from
yeah it just might be you know while
this war is going on today it's like we
have way too many people that creates
way too much emotions like we just want
to put on the best fight possible we
don't want to get involved in politics
I don't know yeah it's a slippery Road
you know it's a it's a slippery Road and
you know the UFC clearly you know while
ESPN and Disney are going super awoke
and losing their ass I think Disney's
down like a billion dollars but uh and
they're you know a value in their stock
um you see Netflix come out and say hey
man because they're losing their ass
gonna lose 2 million subscribers because
this woke movement right in the grand
scheme of things to be like uh-uh dude
we're sick of being called race we're
sick this stuff so you see Netflix going
hey real quick we're gonna put out the
content that the creators want to put
out if you don't agree with it you can
quit yeah that was pretty dope it's like
oh that's a change of tune
well once you start affecting that
bottom dollar change of tune yeah you
know so
we live in a crazy time man crazy time
shifting a little bit now which is great
yes yes the woke stuff yes uh I guess
again it's Bottom Dollar yeah these
business these guys are businessmen
trust me if that woke movement and all
that stuff made tons of money they would
double down on it notice everyone's
pulling back on it
oh yeah okay so this is probably the
last one it's just uh
people are loving this thing up where
John
lahovich when he was cutting weight his
son was cutting weight with him
oh my God
yeah or that you know but I mean it's
like yeah oh my God that is so I'm a
bigger fan and I never wanted to lose
now you never want the guy to look at
that kid looks just like his freaking
Dad too man God it's cute
it is so goddamn cute yeah my son Boston
man I forget I have two Mexican kids I
just forget they're Mexican dude he's
eating flaming hot Cheetos he's eating
his mom's like spicy candy he looks at
me with Papa it's not spicy I'm like I
forgot you're Mexican yup Mexican blood
I forgot dude that is the cutest picture
ever yeah they should frame that
uh you have a fight night this weekend
again they're at they're some of the
main events some of the fights on the
car are pretty good but again they're
edginess to that big July pay-per-view
UFC's known to do this uh Holly Holm
versus Viera Vieira is a baddest tough
fight for Holly man gotta be honest I
don't know what the odds are on
DraftKings chin I would assume Viera
might be a slight favorite there
oh Holly Holmes minus 250. Viera plus
200. oh I'm a huge Holly home fan but I
am a Vieira not a bad bat there beer is
a Savage
Savage plus 195 wow she's going up yeah
and there's a great fight Michelle paid
that crazy oh that's a fun one pots and
nebio plus 100. I can I like the dogs
here Chase Hooper plus 150 I like three
dog parlay here son
all right DraftKings I see what you're
doing
I see exactly what you're doing
all right but yeah yeah so you Gotta
Fight Night some great fights on there
again they're edginess to the big one
but you got Holly Holm Viera in the main
event not mad at that you got Patsy
nebio versus Michael Pierre not mad at
that uh you got Parker Peter Porker
Porter who I love is a heavyweight yeah
Eric Anders Park Jung young that's a
great one
um yeah and they got Chase Hooper
fighting man who I'm a huge fan of he's
a young buck who hopefully figures it
out man but great fight card but I won't
see it until Sunday at night I'll have
to record it because I'm in Philadelphia
Philadelphia
Philadelphia Brotherly Love home of Ben
Franklin and I will be out there
Philadelphia this Thursday Friday
Saturday tickets are almost sold out so
get you some Philly and then one night
only at the my home in La at the
Hollywood improv Los Angeles California
one show 8 P.M shopping friends we got
some monsters on there and very special
guests that's one night only 8 P.M in La
Hollywood improv shop and friends and
then off to Portland Oregon with my
favorite clubs in the world little fact
about Portland the most strip clubs per
capita did you know that
I always said
pale strippers tattoos I always say it
yeah yep a lot of coffee shops a lot of
strippers in Portland dude a lot of
whites uh that's Portland Oregon June
9th through the 11th it looks like the
Twilight up there so that's cool
um that's Portland Oregon helium out
there June 9th the 11th and then San
Francisco Cobbs were my favorite clubs
in the world uh Robin Williams old club
man so that's a special one for me since
my mama loves Robin Williams it's uh
yeah so that is Cobbs San Francisco June
17th through the 18th last time I was
there you came chin yeah if you remember
it was dope that was fun having a great
Club a few times yeah yeah I've done
Cobbs a bunch man uh I haven't done in
years so I'm excited to go back there
because with the lockdown pandemic San
Francisco was on fire is The Purge but
they're back and I will be there at the
Cobbs June 17th through 18th then San
Diego California is the Laugh Factory
San Diego great Club Great location
brand new club July 21st through July
23rd uh but Philly you're up this week
Thursday Friday Saturday the thick boy
crew get tickets at thick boy.com if
you're looking for whiskey they just
restocked it go to thick dot com you
click on the the whiskey tiger thick and
you will see it on there the Gringo
poppy special we about to hit a million
baby that was the goal if we hit a
million the whole Squad here is freaking
going out to a fine fine dinner so
everyone's watch it very closely give me
updates
um yeah every minute every minute so
yeah uh tiger thick whiskey is available
in every state uh for my boys at The
Bourbon Outfitter so if you go to it
you'll see it's a pre-order but they
have it in this week shipped in a week
you're gonna get it it's fantastic I'm
so proud of this whiskey and we finally
got it going man the new merch see your
boy rocking drops uh I think next week
but we have the thick boy Fight Club
merch on there we have the Gringo poppy
uh gear on there we have the uh thick
boy Fight Club hoodies and then the
thick boy trucker hats which you see me
rocking non-stop today's the only day I
didn't wear it but I've been wearing it
every single day on my press tour it's
my favorite hat we've ever done so yeah
man but until I will see this weekend
and like I said I'm at suplex in Philly
buying shoes hanging out come see come
holler at your boy we're doing a collab
merch thing with suplex sneaker shop and
thick boy that will be available only at
suplex you can't get online can't get it
anywhere else where they're just doing a
limited run you can get it on Saturday
when I'm there at noon uh with my boys
at suplex so that's it man Philly see
this weekend enjoy the fight this
Saturday thank you guys for watching
everything I do I love you guys so much
love the support I see the support
through all the drama I'm dealing with I
can't thank you guys enough the best
thing ever happened to me is be out
smoking talk about what I'm going
through
um that what I've been going through
I've always been under the impression
that you just keep marching forward but
sometimes you gotta stop and say hey
this is what's going on in my life this
is why I feel like this weight hurts my
feelings I can't thank you guys enough
for the support I love you guys so much
thank you for watching
um yeah man you guys gave me the best
career I could ever imagine so I love
you guys and like subscribe do all the
other stuff those uh young kids talk
about on YouTube and uh that's it man
stay thick stay safe I love you guys
till next time I'm out